Kirra wrote in saying hey David are
there any companies that you boycott and
why okay so I want to give a disclaimer
the companies I'm about to list to say I
boycott them I don't know if that's a
little strong I mean they're not within
the companies that I shop at I I don't
know how else to describe it I don't
know if it's a boycott per se so for
example I don't shop at Walmart if I
need to go and pick up you know a five
pack of athletic socks which you can do
at any number of stores I opted not to
do it at Walmart I will go to Walmart's
slightly less offensive a cousin Target
or I will go to if there's a local store
I will go to something like that so
Walmart I don't go to Starbucks and
Dunkin Donuts I I don't go to Rite I
mostly make coffee at home but I do
often have meetings at coffee shops etc
and here in Massachusetts it's very easy
to find a Dunkin Donuts basically on
every corner I don't go to Dunkin Donuts
it's been more than ten 10 years 12 15
years since I've been to a Dunkin Donuts
and Starbucks I know that there are
instances like I have this friend who
every time I go to Argentina he loves
Starbucks because it's different than
like the Argentinian coffee shop so he
always wants to go to Starbucks and
because he won't go anywhere else once
on my trip to Argentina I will go to a
Starbucks but otherwise I don't go to a
Starbucks I go to local coffee shops
Delta I avoid flying Delta unless
absolutely unavoidable 18 months ago
coming back from Las Vegas my flight was
so delayed on United that I demanded
they put me on a different flight and
they put me on Delta and they got me
home on time so it worked out but
because of their anti-union policies I
tend to avoid flying Delta Airlines as
far as beers go
I avoid like Coors and and the
anheuser-busch type you know Budweiser
Bud Light etc not only do I think that
it's terrible beer I also don't love
supporting those companies so I try to
go with the microbrews of course some of
the microbrews have been purchased by
the big beer manufacturers are you ever
really sure unless you look it up I
don't know but I try to go with like the
the local micro brews where I know
something about it there's so
here in New England or some European
microbrews or some places have South
American beers when you go places those
are these boycotts I don't know I think
for it to be a boycott you have to kind
of see the unethical business practices
going on at these places and say
actively I don't want to support this I
do with with Walmart for sure Delta I
mean I think that applies I would say
that definitely applies too and for me I
mean just it by nature of being vegan
there's entire industries that I boycott
per se right and there's places I can't
go to I can't really go to McDonald's or
Arby's I don't I don't buy products from
Purdue or hood you know there's there's
a whole list for me I would say that
reminds me you know I do I boycott fast
food I don't know I haven't been to a
fast-food restaurant for more than 15
years and I used to every once in a
while go to like Wendy's or Burger King
or McDonald's I haven't been to any of
those for more than 15 years I guess
it's a boycott I mean I don't know I I
know fewer and fewer people that go to
those places you could you could justify
it in a certain way because you say well
those those foods are very unhealthy
yeah and for me I don't want to put my
money towards that so I guess the other
qualifies so those are some I can't
really think of others I mean it's part
you know with cars other than a Jeep
Grand Cherokee that I had in high school
I think that's the only one well no my
first car was a $1500 Pontiac Firebird
okay and then at one point I had a Jeep
Grand Cherokee since then I do
deliberately avoid buying American cars
I find the design sort of clunky and I
just buy foreign cars so am i boycotting
American cars what does it even mean to
be an American car the the Volkswagen I
had five or six years ago was the first
of that model to be built in the United
States although it is a foreign company
so at this point I don't even know if
that has meaning but is that a boycott I
don't know and even American cars now
are being made elsewhere manufactured in
Mexico or other countries yes Trump's oh
so eloquently talks about yes so I guess
those are some of the companies I quote
boycott or just avoid going to